la culture de la canne à sucre est une
activité agricole traditionnelle à l'île
de la réunion
elle constitue le premier produit
d'exportation le sucre de canne
les cannes sont coupées dans les
chambres est ensuite transporté vers les
usines par des tracteurs ou de grands
camions appelé cachalot des moyens de
transport modernes qui n'existaient pas
lors de l'introduction de l'industrie de
la canne à la réunion au début du 19e
siècle
les transports se faisait en charrettes
tractées par des baies des chalets de
boeuf comme les appelle les réunionnais
souvent associé à la can mais qui ne
servaient pas seulement transporter les
rebuts sucré j'arrêtais qui est utilisé
pour beaucoup pour plein de choses
récupérer les marchandises al adha qui
arrivent par le train qui arrivera le
train la dass à dire pour amener dans
tous les villages même récupérer les
corps au beau joe de plage pour amener
aux fours à chaux
ben tu te tais fait en charge quasiment
110 habite à pierrefonds à 31 ans il est
le seul conducteur de char est dite de
boeuf à la réunion dont l'une va
retrouver peut-être à charette et un
boeuf mais du style comme ça maintenant
il devient unique d'en haut nil parce
que sur pas le commandement pour pouvoir
dire j'arrête de boeuf mais aussi
beaucoup de repos de cette image là avec
réussi balout vous mettre 4 5 tonnes des
dents c'est d'arriver à l'énergie tandis
que le un bel hommage que de temps
dedans il existait donc plusieurs
modèles de charrette à boeufs à la
réunion et n'allez pas dire à un samedi
que son moyen de transport est
aujourd'hui dépassé il peut même aller
là où les véhicules d'aujourd'hui ne
passe pas à quand la pluie tombe là même
de la médiane un couvent a traversé des
mois et là oh ouais bof mais savoir plus
d'ailleurs n'y a pas derrière
dans une époque où les transports ce
temps surtout en voiture le jeune
conducteur de charette boeuf a dû
s'adapter ils ne transportent pas
beaucoup de marchandises la majeure
partie de son activité est tournée vers
le tourisme les gens qui arrivent dans
son activité et découvre ce qui se
passait autrefois dans ce monde avec
aulas à l'époque il y avait pas encore
le système d'irrigation comme on peut le
voir au travers des activités qu'ils
proposent
visites guidées balades ou encore
mariage 110 transmet une passion
directement hérité de son grand-père
ben le grand père malade mais là le
grand mère bain tv pas trop que une
telle charade boeuf
je me dis comme ça ben puisqu'il a
dominé tout compris que j'étais à
l'hôpital à bois et son savoir faire
auprès du plus qu'un savoir faire
c'est un héritage que le jeune
saint-pierrois est fière de transmettre
aux générations du troisième millénaire
où pratiquer quelque chose d'unique à la
réunion mon fils était